le premier texte à l'assemblée nationale
ce sera une réforme de l'assurance
chômage mais pour prolonger la réforme
qui a été réalisé durant le premier
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro et dans le
même temps et bien le gouvernement
travaille sur un second volet de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage ou
olivier dussopt pts et bien à l'idée
c'est d'adapter cette assurance chômage
en fonction du taux d'emploi dans notre
pays c'est à dire que quand ça va bien
on durcit un petit peu les droits quand
ça va mal eh bien on renforce les droits
des locaux des allocataires nous avons
deux priorités et vous l'avez rappelé la
première priorité c'est de proroger les
règles de l'indemnisation matière
d'assurance chômage un décret a été pris
en 2019 après l'échec des discussions
sociales du dialogue social autour d'un
accord interprofessionnel
ce décret a été pris mais n'avaient pas
été mises en oeuvre immédiatement et la
réforme de l'indemnisation de
l'assurance chômage n'est entrée en
vigueur qu'en 2021 après les périodes de
confinement aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de prolonger ces règles jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 2023 pour avoir du
recul et pourrait faire une véritable
évaluation mais pour faire aussi en
sorte que cette réforme puisse appliquer
pleinement notamment la question du
bonus malus dans les 7 les sept secteurs
réputés pour avoir des contrats courts
et que cette réforme doit encadrer et
puis nous avons un deuxième objectif que
présente la république a dit le 14
juillet qui l'a rappelé qu'elle fait en
sorte que s'adresse cette assurance
chômage ces règles d'indemnisation
puisse être vu et tenir compte de la
situation économique l'os comme nous
sommes dans la situation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec des chefs
d'entreprise qui n'arrivent pas à
recruter avec 7% de chômage un peu plus
et les logiques les normales d'inciter à
la reprise est d'inciter à la reprise
d'activité et puis quand le marché
travail du travail se dégradent il est
aussi normal que la règle soit plus
protectrice c'est ce que nous allons
discuter cet automne avec les
partenaires sociaux pour voir sur quels
critères on détermine quand ça va mieux
et quand ça va moins bien et comment on
détermine ce qui relève de
l'assoupissement ou d'une forme de
durcissement donc discussions cet
automne avec les partenaires sociaux une
réforme qui sera discuté au parlement le
temps de la dé discuter avec les
partenaires sociaux et d'ouvrir une
concertation l'assurance chômage relève
des objets du dialogue social et les
meilleures formules les meilleures
situations sont celles qui naissent d'un
accord national interprofessionnel est
donc dans un premier temps nous
prolongeons les règles actuelles et nous
en sorte que toute la réforme s'applique
y compris le bonus malus dans un second
temps nous ouvrant cette concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux est ce que
ce sera une réforme de l'assurance
chômage par territoire c'est-à-dire
comprendra en compte la situation
économique dans chaque territoire je ne
sais pas le dire à ce stade c'est le
modèle canadien vous décrivez je ne sais
pas si à l'échelle d'un pays comme la
france nous savons mettre en place un
système qui permette des différents
indemnisation d'un territoire à l'autre
ne sont pas le canada le canada a une
vertu de modèle dans le sens où c'est un
des premiers pays à avoir mis en place
des règles qui s'assouplissent quand le
marché du travail se dégradent et qui se
renforce sur le marché du travail
s'améliore mais tout ce qui était au
canada n'est pas forcément duplicable en
france alors pour conclure rapidement
une question sur la réforme des
retraites où là encore la concertation
va se dérouler à l'automne mais du côté
de la droite sénatoriale eh bien on le
dit dès cet automne dans l'examen du
budget de la sécurité sociale est bien
la majorité de droite sénatoriale votre
à un report de l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite
au moins 64 ans a dit le président du
groupe plr bruno retailleau pourquoi le
gouvernement ne suivrait pas ce vote car
eh bien la réforme du gouvernement est
assez similaire
j'ai été mise des comptes publics en et
nice du travail et à chaque paie l'effet
cesse chaque projet loi de financement
la sécurité sociale à la droite
sénatoriale a voté cette réforme elle a
voté cette mesure et nous avons toujours
dit notre opposition à la mesure telle
qu'elle a été présentée pour une raison
très simple finalement
la réforme de la retraite uniquement par
le prisme de l'âge n'est pas une réforme
juste ce que nous voulons et c'est de
faire l'objet de discussions le
président de la république a aussi
rappelé cet horizon c'est à la fois un
système de retraite qui soit plus
lisible soit plus juste qui ne viennent
pas sanctionner les polypensionnés qui
tiennent mieux qu'ils prennent mieux en
compte la pénibilité et l'usure
professionnelle qui permettent
d'accompagner le maintien dans l'emploi
des seniors qui permet aussi d'avoir une
retraite minimale à 1100 euros soit 85%
du smic toutes ces mesures
d'amélioration et évidemment un coût
dans un système qui est déjà
déséquilibré pour le financer nous
savons que nous devons tous
collectivement travailler plus
travailler plus chacun mais travailler
plus c'est aussi permettre le plein
emploi et fait en sorte que nous soyons
plus nombreux en france à travailler et
donc c'est un ensemble prendre cette
réforme de leur attrait de la retraite
uniquement sous l'angle de l'âge c'est
le risque d'une grande injustice ne se
sera pas forcément une mesure d'âge dans
la réforme du gouvernement ce port est
aussi une augmentation de la durée de
cotisation premier ministre a dit qu'il
n'aimait ni total ni tabou et nous
sommes aussi avec une idée après le
conseil national de la refondation
annoncée par le président de la
république c'est de nourrir un dialogue
avec les partenaires sociaux beaucoup
s'accordent sur les objectifs en termes
d'amélioration de justice
et après il faut trouver les moyens de
le financer nous sommes aussi ouverts à
ces propositions
[Musique]